PAUL KINLAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
And I'm with Paul Lewis today.
PAUL LEWIS: Hello.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
And we're here from
sunny London?
Rainy London?
PAUL LEWIS: Miserable London,
to be honest.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, it's
a little bit crazy.
And today we are talking about
Chrome Apps and Web Intents.
Our normal producer, Peter--
Paul, I was going to say.
PAUL LEWIS: Another Paul.
Let's be honest, it's easier
if everybody's called Paul.
We say this every week and it's
actually true, easier if
everybody's a Paul.
So let's just call
him Paul LePage.
PAUL KINLAN: Paul LePage?
Peter LePage.
PAUL LEWIS: Peter LePage,
all right.
PAUL KINLAN: So anyway,
we're in our
brand New London studio.
It's pretty cool.
We pretty like it.
It's like a little pod.
And we're two Pauls, so
it's like two peas.
PAUL LEWIS: Two Pauls
in a pod?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: I've been planning
that joke all day,
not telling anyone about this.
PAUL LEWIS: And you've just
dropped it, boom.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So anyway, yes, let's get
started properly.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: We're going to talk
about Web Intents and how
Web Intents is a core
integral part of
the Chrome Apps ecosystem.
So over the last couple of
weeks we've been running
Chrome App sessions.
Chrome Apps are a way that we're
trying to make these web
applications--
applications that you develop
normally [? with ?]
HTML, JavaScript, and CSS--
look and feel native on
the user's system.
And one of the things that
we've been pushing inside
Chrome at least is the
idea of Web Intents.
So what are Web Intents?
PAUL LEWIS: That's
a good question.
What are Web Intents?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: They sort
of fall into two
categories, don't they?
Like inter-application
communication is one of things
that you use it for, and
application discovery.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Shall we nail
each one in turn?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, shall
we do that?
So we'll start off with
a little quick demo.
We have a nice little video
transition effect as well,
which is going to be pretty cool
if we do it correctly.
Look at that.
PAUL LEWIS: Nice.
PAUL KINLAN: That
was pretty cool.
So this is my screen.
And I'm going to show you some
stuff about Web Intents.
So we have a basic application
called Imagemator.
And it's a simple application.
It doesn't do much other
than trying to
orchestrate actions on images.
Now with a traditional
application, when you build
integrations to third-party
systems like, say, Google
Drive, you have to do a deep
JavaScript-based or maybe a
server-side-based integration
with the service.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
So you've got like tokens, and
all these API requests, and
there's just tons of work.
And this is like per service
or per application that you
want to integrate with, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So hopefully this will work.
I just realized I've deleted
all my extensions.
So this might work.
So Cloud File Picker,
this is an
application that we've installed.
PAUL LEWIS: So all you did there
was you just clicked on
the box and Chrome's
taken over.
PAUL KINLAN: So basically our
application has asked Chrome
for a list of applications that
support the ability to
pick an image from somewhere.
PAUL LEWIS: Ah-ha, OK.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's
pretty cool.
And as you can see we hactually
have-- actually?
PAUL LEWIS: Hactually.
PAUL KINLAN: We have no
applications installed, so
we'll go and install one.
This list comes from the
Chrome Web Store.
Applications in the Chrome Web
Store can declare their
intent, what they can support,
actions that they can support.
So this application is saying
that I can support the ability
to pick an image
from somewhere.
So I'll add it in.
We'll launch our application.
And if I'm all logged in, oh,
here we go, this is awesome.
Let's pick that image.
I believe I have copyright
to that image.
So we brought our image
into our application.
It's pretty cool.
We can do some of this stuff.
So we can say, I'm going
to edit this image.
So we ask again, the browser,
to say are there a list of
applications that I can
use to edit images.
And again, in this case,
there aren't any.
But we can install one.
And then we go.
So, Hello.
You can see it's
updated there.
We're just going to send it
back to our application.
Hello.
PAUL LEWIS: So that happened
really quickly.
So what happened was, you
dispatched an intent.
The first intent was like,
hey, are there any
applications that can
pick images for me?
And then the second thing, once
you've got the image data
back is you said, is there
anything out there that can
also edit images for me?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
And so then when it sent it off
to Mememator, it made the
changes, and it sent the data
back, the updated image back
to your Imagemator application,
right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: And all the
communication there, the
inter-application communication,
was done with
Web Intents.
PAUL KINLAN: Web Intents or
JavaScript inside the client.
PAUL LEWIS: Wait, if only, is
the code simple to use?
PAUL KINLAN: The code is
very simple, my friend.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, it's
a dream come true.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's
have a quick look.
So index.js, there's about
30 lines of code in this
application.
And all we really have to do is
ignore the fact that I've
called startActivity.call.
I've just been playing around
with different syntax methods.
But essentially, we just called
startActivity on an
object, or on the
window.navigator object.
PAUL LEWIS: So we call
window.navigator.startActivity,
and it looks like the second
parameter that you've got
there is the intent itself.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so we've
defined the intent here.
This is the old syntax.
And we're going to show you
today building a proper
Chrome, not a normal web app,
a Chrome App, exactly what's
going to happen and the way that
we're kind of pushing the
spec forward.
But we have an intent object
with the type pick of image.
So we've basically asked the
browser, is there a service
out there that can
pick images?
PAUL LEWIS: Huh, so really we're
talking about two lines
of code here, right?
We've got this create an intent,
which we sort of
define these things, and I
guess we're going to talk
about what those are.
And then the next things to say
to navigator.startActivity
with that intent, and it goes
off and does the thing.
That looks pretty easy
to me, mate.
PAUL KINLAN: It is.
It is pretty easy.
The interesting thing is that
the way that we've been kind
of pushing Web Intents
is that actually this
is all on the web.
So it's like HTML-based web
applications are HTML-based
applications.
And a lot of people asked for
the ability to bridge to
native applications.
So they want to kind of talk
to their Photoshop, those
types of apps.
And whilst we don't have that
direct bridge right now,
Chrome Applications is like
the next step along where
Chrome applications look and
feel like they're installed,
or they will do, not right now
on the Mac, but we're going to
go through this in
a bit as well.
But they'll look like
they're native
applications on the system.
So you could launch an
application from your browser
and it would look like it's
just talking to a normal
native app and it's
communicating over Web Intents.
PAUL LEWIS: Nice.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's
pretty cool.
I think we should start with
the demo though, shall we?
PAUL LEWIS: Oh yeah, actually
show how to do this?
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So the first
thing that most
people want to do is--
Well, I'll back up
a little bit.
There are two things that
normally happen.
One, an application broadcasts
like a request out, say, hey,
I need to share this link.
And then there's another
application on the other side
which says, I can receive links
that are sent to me.
And we're going to start with
the first one, basically.
We're going to start with the
ability to actually share a
link out to another
application.
And this application could be
a website or it could be a
native or, say, a Chrome
App at least.
So we'll start.
Hopefully everyone can
see my screen OK.
I'm going to jump down a little
bit because I think
we've got my face in the way.
But we'll start off
with yeoman.
Actually, we won't start
We'll make a directory
called invoke.
You need to tell me if I make
any spelling mistakes.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm watching.
All eyes on you, mate.
PAUL KINLAN: Like a hawk.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: So invoke, so we're
now in that directory.
We'll use a tool that Addy
Osmani and Paul Irish built
through the [? Wii ?]
called Yeoman.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeoman.io, if you
have not come across it, it's
a brilliant way of creating
your apps.
So you should definitely
check that out.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So basically, we're using Yeoman
to bootstrap all the
kind of legwork that you need
to make your Chrome App.
So we'll start off with
this, yeoman init.
And what should we call
the application?
PAUL LEWIS: Invoke.
PAUL KINLAN: Invoke?
Yeah, that's it, Invoke.
App is the description.
And then it's going to ask me
about the different types of
API I want to use.
PAUL LEWIS: So would this create
the manifest for you?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So Chrome Applications come with
a manifest, some icons,
some localized descriptions.
If we look at this now, so we'll
just go into the app
directory and clear
the screen.
We'll do ls.
We have the locals directory.
The two icons we need
are a 16 pixel icon
and a 128 pixel icon.
The index file and some of the
kind of bootstrap code.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
So if you've been watching over
the past few weeks, one
of the first ones we did, first
sessions, we created a
Hello World application.
And we've just done pretty much
the same deal in one line
on the command line, which
is pretty neat.
PAUL KINLAN: So we
should probably
load this up, I think.
Desktop, WebIntentsLiveDemos,
Intents this is my little
folder for doing all
things live.
There we are, Invoke.
We'll see the application
called Invoke here.
We invoke it and it doesn't
do much at all, right?
It's just a screen.
It's a window screen
that looks--
PAUL LEWIS: Pretty blank,
to be honest.
PAUL KINLAN: --pretty blank,
pretty boring.
PAUL LEWIS: Like your face.
PAUL KINLAN: Should we
make it was cool?
Like my face?
PAUL LEWIS: Like your
face most days.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
Thanks, man.
PAUL LEWIS: No worry, bro.
PAUL KINLAN: Burn me live in
front of millions of people,
thousands of people, I don't
know how many we got.
Anyway, let's get going
with the code right.
So essentially, this
is our application.
We want to add a button which
shares, invokes the intent.
But we want to kind of share
some data with it.
So we'll have an input type
equals URL, call URL, and then
we'll just share the out.
I'll say up front, some of this
code is not going to be
the sexiest code.
We're not going to use
addEventListener, and all that
type of stuff.
We're just going to kind of do
it as quickly as possible.
So let's view the index file.
As we can see, we just
have an Invoke.
It looks like what we saw on
the screen a minute ago.
So let's add this in, script
source="index.js." I'm doing
this for a very special
reason.
PAUL LEWIS: Which would be
presumably Content Security
Policy, my friend.
PAUL KINLAN: Indeed, Content
Security Policy.
So Content Security Policy
means you can't inline
JavaScript.
We have this in Chrome
applications because Chrome
Apps have elevated access to
APIs which we would never
normally have on a webpage.
And we don't want people
to do script injection.
So you have to hide everything
in your own script.
So let's, index.js.
Now, what was the code?
So that's our JavaScript code.
Make sure the file is made.
Let's put input type="url,"
id="url." There we are.
So that's our input type.
Let's save that, go back,
standards HTML kind of things
that you'd expect.
Let's make a button, id="share,"
call it share, its
original name again.
PAUL LEWIS: That's what it
says on the tin though.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it does
what it says on the tin.
So it's pretty bland,
pretty boring.
But you'll see what happens.
So let's onload.
So we're basically doing the
window dot onload event here.
And all we're going to do
is hook up the events.
PAUL LEWIS: So we're going
to capture the URL.
And then we're going to say,
when you click on the share
button, we'd now actually like
to invoke an intent to
actually share.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes,
exactly right.
It's all pretty simple stuff.
So var share equals.
This is like when I write with
a pen and a piece of paper, I
have to speak out every
single word.
PAUL LEWIS: If I'm honest, I'm
terrified of paper nowadays
because I can't Command
Z or Control Z
when I write something.
PAUL KINLAN: You ever get that
thing where your hand kind of
like cramps up when you're
writing and you can't use it?
PAUL LEWIS: I don't
write anymore.
I haven't done this for years.
PAUL KINLAN: Share.onclick, so
when the user clicks the share
button, we'll call this
function, again, it's not the
sexiest code in the world, but
var i = new WebKitIntent.
PAUL LEWIS: So why are
we prefixing that?
PAUL KINLAN: So right now,
although we're working through
the standardization process,
the thing that we do to be
kind of good web citizens is we
prefix all the objects that
we create from the spec.
Just so that if the spec changes
and another browser
vendor who's implemented the
specification updates theirs,
then they're not relying
on what kind of
this one intent object.
They know that the WebKit intent
will be potentially to
XYZ intent.
PAUL LEWIS: So this is actually
like a spec piece of
functionality that we're working
through right now.
It's not like Chrome specific
or anything like that.
It's just that we've
implemented
it with Chrome Apps.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, exactly.
So what I'm doing now is I'm
passing in a special object
into the WebKit intent
constructor.
And basically, this object
just describes some basic
information about what we're
looking for on the system.
So we're going to look
for an action of
webintents.org/share.
PAUL LEWIS: So the question I
was going to ask is the fact
that you've used webintents.org
as the action.
So first of all, why is it
a URL in the action?
And second of all, does
it have to be a
webintent.org URL.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
good question.
So the answer is, well,
no, it doesn't.
I'll start off the end, it
doesn't have to be just
webintents.org.
But essentially what happens is
when we ask the browser for
a list of services, it does just
pure string match on all
the services that have the
exact same action.
So if nothing supports
webintents.org/share, then we
won't find it in that list.
The reason why we're using a
domain is because we think
documentation is key
to the spec.
So the idea is that the share
intent might live outside the
W3C process defined in the
specification about how to
transfer data across share, how
you should share images,
how you should share video, and
all that type of stuff.
So webintents.org/share
documents the best practices
for sharing data.
If another service provider
wants to do their own version
of share, then that's fine.
They could do like
XYZservice.com/share.
The thing is that if someone
invokes webintents.org/share,
any application that
has to do with XYZ
won't be in that list.
So that's all we're doing.
We're basically just
prefixing it.
It's kind of like in Android--
or in Java, sorry, where you
have reverse domain notation,
com. whatever it is.
We're kind of trying to be webby
behind this whole fact.
So text/html.
So we're just going to assume
that it's like a URL to a HTML
page that we're sharing
at the moment.
PAUL LEWIS: So this is the MIME
type of the data that
we're going to be sending out?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
And it doesn't have to
be a pure MIME type.
It could be the word person.
But again, what happens is we
find a list of services that
support the action for share and
then we filter that list.
Because there might be like 10,
20, 30 different services
the user's got installed
for sharing data.
But we want to be
quite specific.
We want to find the services
that support this like sharing
of links essentially, text/html,
HTML webpages.
And the final thing is the
payload, is the actual piece
of data that we want to share.
So in this case, it's just
url.value, which, in theory,
if all goes well, should
be the value
that we put into the--
PAUL LEWIS: Do you need
to actually start
the activity on that?
PAUL KINLAN: You're right.
I would like to say I
purposefully left that out,
but, no, I didn't.
I forgot.
So we have our WebKit
intent object.
It's not actually doing a single
thing at the moment.
It's just sitting there
being quiet.
So what we want to try and do is
we want to ask the browser
for a list of services.
So
navigator.webkitStartActivity.
There we go.
We'll start the activity.
PAUL LEWIS: So that's
16 lines of code.
That's pretty simple stuff for
actually sharing a URL.
PAUL KINLAN: And most of it is
just to make it look pretty.
PAUL LEWIS: And you did.
PAUL KINLAN: I did.
PAUL LEWIS: Well done.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank
you very much.
So if all goes well, test.com,
we press Share.
PAUL LEWIS: So you now got a
number of services that take
text HTML links.
And they've registered
their intent against
webintents.org/share.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So these three services here
have said that they support
the ability to share
text/html.
We have two installed.
These two ones here are local
to my machine at the moment.
The share link to Twitter is
actually in the Chrome Web
Store, but it wouldn't
work with this demo.
And then we have wordpress.com,
which I haven't
installed and we have the
ability to add to Chrome.
I'm going to share a
link to Twitter.
PAUL LEWIS: So that was
great example of
app discovery there.
Because you haven't got the
Wordpress one installed, but
it said, well, I know for a fact
that this application can
deal with that, it's told me
that when the app was uploaded
to the Chrome Web Store, so
it will offer that to you.
So even if you haven't got an
application installed, it's
worth remembering that the
Chrome Web Store can actually
say, here's a number of services
that can actually
solve this particular issue.
This is also good for you
as a developer as well.
Because you don't need to
necessarily worry too much
ahead of time.
As long as you've tagged these
things correctly with the
correct types and so forth, that
services will be matched
up for you by the browser.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, exactly.
So as you can see the URL, has
been embedded with the URL
that we've shared.
I've actually put it in and I've
also embellished it with
a little bit of my own text.
PAUL LEWIS: That is
beautifully done.
PAUL KINLAN: And I'm going
to share it out.
So now we've shared out to
the world wide web--
PAUL LEWIS: That was
pretty easy.
PAUL KINLAN: --test.com.
It's probably going to be the
least useful tweet you'll
probably see in a while.
But it's pretty cool.
I like the whole idea.
So that's pretty interesting,
right?
We've been able to build
an application.
Let's go to here.
Oops, I apologize.
That has been able to invoke
in, let's say, 16 lines of
nicely formatted code, the
ability to basically
interconnect with another
application.
That's pretty cool, right?
It's really hard to actually
say how easy it is.
Although, I could say
how easy it is.
PAUL LEWIS: It is easy.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
You know what sometimes
we sound like?
Have you seen those
infomercials?
PAUL LEWIS: No.
Oh, yeah.
I know where you're
going with this.
This doesn't come out well
for me, does it?
PAUL KINLAN: No.
PAUL LEWIS: Excellent.
PAUL KINLAN: But essentially so,
we've got the ability to
share images, edit images.
If you want to integrate with an
image editing application,
all you do is [INAUDIBLE] say
share, you say edit, and then
you give the data that you want
to edit to the browser,
which will then delegate it
across to another application.
PAUL LEWIS: So can you
can send BLOBs?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so
you can send BLOBs.
We had a bug a while ago where
if you sent a BLOB it would
get garbage collected, which
meant on the other side you
couldn't read it, read the
BLOB out properly.
But I believe that's
fixed now.
So you could basically
say, well, I have a
500 megabyte file.
It's in my browser, it's in my
tab, it's on my local system.
And I want to deliver it
to, say, I don't know,
photoshop.com, if they
supported intents.
They don't at the moment,
but if you want to.
If they did, then rather than
actually passing the data
through the web, you'd pass it
like from browser tab to
browser tab.
So these two applications can
be made to work completely
offline and talk together.
PAUL LEWIS: Brilliant.
PAUL KINLAN: Which I think
is pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, especially
if you're
talking about large files.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
So that was pretty simple.
That was just the application
that invokes an intent.
PAUL LEWIS: So now we need to
talk about the other side of
this, right?
Like what if I'm making an app
today, and I want to be able
to say, OK, I can deal with,
say, this share stuff or
something else.
How do I say, OK, I'm ready
to receive intents?
PAUL KINLAN: I before
E, except after--
I did a presentation the other
day and I'd spelled receive
incorrectly.
PAUL LEWIS: Across
all of them?
PAUL KINLAN: Across every
single slide.
So at least I was consistent.
PAUL LEWIS: Consistently
incorrect.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Could be
a strapline, that.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's build an
application which receives
intent data.
PAUL LEWIS: You might need to
come down on the screen.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, sure thing.
That's a very good point
Yeoman init chromeapp.
So you actually built the
original Chome App generator.
PAUL LEWIS: Certainly did.
PAUL KINLAN: So now
it's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: You bolted some
stuff on, didn't you?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes,
I made it work.
PAUL LEWIS: Harsh.
It worked great, but then
Chrome Apps changed.
PAUL KINLAN: You can say
Chrome Apps changed 16
versions ago.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, yes,
that's true.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry.
PAUL LEWIS: It is worth
mentioning, as we always do
actually, that some of this
stuff is experimental and it
does change.
So it is worth keeping
an eye on that.
PAUL KINLAN: So like the Web
Intent spec is still being
worked on and will change
in response to developer
feedback, likewise the
Chrome Apps APIs.
So here we go.
Wow.
I'm doing it again, ls la.
So we'll start off with
the manifest, right?
The reason why we start off with
the manifest is you have
to be able to tell the system
what you support.
So your application needs to
declare to the browser, I can
share links.
So we'll start with this.
We'll do an intents
declaration.
It is an object [? to ?]
[? write, ?]
which means it's keyed off the
actual type of intent.
So share.
So basically what we've said
here is my application will be
able to share.
We haven't actually provided
any extra information.
But we can.
It's an array because your
application could, in theory,
support the same action, but
deliver the data to multiple
different places.
PAUL LEWIS: Crazy.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it doesn't
really affect the Chrome Apps
so much because everything
technically gets delivered to
the background page.
But for a hosted app or an
extension, you can actually
choose the very specific page
that you want the intent data
to be delivered to.
So here we go, type.
So you don't have to repeat
yourself multiple times.
You can actually say,
[? text/*. ?]
So if anyone shares anything
that is text-based.
PAUL LEWIS: All the texts.
PAUL KINLAN: All the texts, so
text plain, text uri-list,
text HTML, text JPEG.
I was checking to see if
you were listening.
So type, text, title.
Oh man, I can't spell,
RECEIVE TEST.
Do you want to say a random word
just to prove it's live?
PAUL LEWIS: Truth.
PAUL KINLAN: TRUTH.
Is that OK?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: For reals.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So in the normal
Web Intents world, inside
Chrome hosted apps at least, you
normally specify a href.
You don't with Chrome Apps
because everything gets
delivered to the background
page.
And we're going to cover that
in a little minute.
So that's our application.
It has declared its intent.
So, I'll tell you way, you
might as well load it in.
PAUL LEWIS: So the Chrome Web
Store, if you were to push
that app live to the Chrome
Web Store, the Chrome Web
Store would look at the intent
and sort of keep a track on
that and say, OK, so if somebody
then dispatches an
intent with that type, I know
that this application
can now handle it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes,
exactly right.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
So that's all you have to do.
PAUL KINLAN: So this
is our Receive app.
It is very much like the Invoke
app when it first came
into fruition.
PAUL LEWIS: It is gorgeous.
PAUL KINLAN: It is beautiful,
isn't it?
PAUL LEWIS: It is.
It's your finest work.
PAUL KINLAN: And that's the end
of our presentation there.
PAUL LEWIS: Excellent,
thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: No, cool.
So let's actually put some
implementation into this.
Main.js, we didn't touch
main.js before
in the Invoke app.
So main.js, it's not like main
function in C and other
programming languages.
We've just arbitrarily called
main.js as the file that's
going to be run on first run.
PAUL LEWIS: So this is the
JavaScript that's running as
our background page.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: We call it
background page, but really
it's like a background script.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so kind of
Chrome goes through the list
of scripts, injects them into
a background page, and runs
them so they can be sequentially
laid out.
Now, this is our declaration
of saying what happens when
the user clicks the button to
launch that application.
Well in our case, it's
pretty simple.
The user will see the
window here open.
We want to do some with the
data that comes in.
And where that happens is
right at the end here,
intentData.
So the callback that you attach
to addListener for the
onLaunched actually has a
parameter called intentData.
That's data that's been injected
into your application
from either another website or
another Chrome Application.
So let's get into this now.
We'll create a window.
Oh, I can spell function,
appWindow.
We can get a callback from
Chrome when the window is
being created.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, so that Receive
window that we just
saw a moment ago, when that gets
fired up, we call this
anonymous function that
you're declaring now.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So the anonymous function
allows us to
do a couple of things.
We could manipulate the window,
make it large, make it
small, minimize, maximize
if we wanted to,
when it's been created.
But in this case, we actually
get access to the DOM.
PAUL LEWIS: One thing that's
worth pointing out here is
you're accessing contentWindow,
which is a
recent change that we made.
So the app window that comes
back is a Chrome App window.
It's not necessarily
what you'd expect.
It's not the DOM window that
we, as web developers,
will be used to.
So what we do is we are
accessing the DOM window
element through this
contentWindow property on appWindow.
OK, cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, which allows
us to inject methods, new
functions, new data
into a window
that's just been opened.
It's a little bit atypical when
you think about the way
that you develop applications
on the web.
You very rarely get access,
especially when you open
another remote window, you
can't inject data in.
But because everything's kind
of like tightly contained
inside this app, we give you
that ability to do that.
Which is kind of cool because it
allows us to deliver intent
data to another window.
So let me just, what is it?
Index.html, right?
We will simply put in a
paragraph id="result." And we
will then create a
script, scropt.
Oh, wow.
PAUL LEWIS: Or scriopt.
PAUL KINLAN: A scriopt.
I like inventing new tags.
This should be good, right?
Source="index.js," script,
brilliant, we don't have
index.js made, so let's
go and make it.
And using Vim, we always get a
lot of questions about what
text editors.
You always use Sublime.
PAUL LEWIS: I do.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm using Vim,
which is vi improved.
I actually find that I only
use like 1% of the whole.
I usually like insert and
delete, and that's about it,
and split window,
as we can tell.
So anyway, I get distracted
really easily, don't I?
PAUL LEWIS: I wasn't going to
say anything, but yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Onload, so the
window's been loaded.
So what we should do is we
should, first off, get a
reference by ID result.
It's a result,
result.textContent =
window.intentData.intent.data.
PAUL LEWIS: So you're grabbing
hold of that intent data that
we injected into the page.
You're grabbing the intent
and then the data
properties of that.
And then we're going to set that
as the actual value that
we'll send out to the page.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and all this
is just proving is that
we can share data to the Chome
App from our existing Chrome
Application.
So if this works, cool.
So it looks like
it didn't work.
But that's because I just
refreshed the page.
And I actually was a
little bit silly.
Invoke.
I just need to remove
Twitter for now.
We found a bug about 15
minutes before this
presentation.
Here we go.
So test.com and truth.
It's not a proper URL, but we'll
hopefully get the idea.
RECEIVE TEST TRUTH is in
there because we've
added it into Chrome.
It says it supports the share,
to share text/HTML links at
least, Select.
PAUL LEWIS: And there we go.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: Well done, sir.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
And there's a couple of
other things that
you can do as well.
If you want to post data back,
you can just basically take
the intent object can call post
result, and it will tend
data back to the calling
application.
So we have a bidirectional
communication channel.
Yeah, I mean that's pretty
much it, right?
Let me just uninstall
this application.
No, I won't uninstall it.
I will go to paul.kinlan.me
because I know there's not
going to be anything
contentious on it.
We can share directly
from Chrome, RECEIVE
TEST, if this all works.
There we go.
PAUL LEWIS: My goodness, mate.
PAUL KINLAN: So we have Chrome
App talking to Chrome App,
Chrome Web Browser Applications
on the open web
talking to application that
are installed inside the
user's machine.
So we've got multiple different
ways that we can
pass data across and
it's all using the
same intents mechanism.
It's pretty cool.
I think it's pretty powerful.
There's one last thing
I want to talk about.
And we're going to show
a little bit of code.
So here we go.
I apologize about this.
There we go.
So this is the code I
prepared earlier.
Just in case anything ever goes
wrong, I had backups.
So window.js, there we go.
Do you remember Blue Peter when
they had "This is one I
prepared earlier?"
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, this is one
you prepared earlier.
PAUL KINLAN: This is
one [INAUDIBLE]
actually developed.
And it's in our Chrome Apps
samples on GitHub.
The reason why I want
to show you this is
because a couple of things.
The first is that the action
here is not a normal action.
It's not http/webintents.org.
It's an action that is very
specific to his application.
So he's developed these two
applications and he wants to
talk between them.
And he's basically said, well,
in this remote application,
I've isolated a piece of
functionality which doesn't
fit into share, edit,
pick, it's just very
specific to my app.
I just want to target that.
I'll tell you what, if I get
rid of this line, in the
normal Web Intents world, what
would happen then is the
picker would appear looking
for applications that are
installed that says
chrome-extension/app/op.
It's very specific to
his own use case.
But you still get this
picker, right?
And actually what he has
basically said is that I don't
want the picker, I know I'm
talking to my application or
another application.
There should be no kind of
resolution of services in
between and selection
for the user.
So he's using a thing called
explicit intents.
And explicit intents is
this little bit here.
So when you build up your WebKit
Intent, if you include
the word service, in theory it
could be http:// a public URL
which supports intents.
But right now, it's just locked
down to the Chrome
extension namespace.
And this code is basically
saying that I'll use the Web
Intents infrastructure to
deliver data, but I will call
that action up there, app2/op,
directly on the
chrome-extension/GUID/generated
background.
PAUL LEWIS: So this seems like
a way of shortcutting that
normal process that we were
saying where you sort of say,
well, I want an application
that can deal with this.
You're now saying, I know
specifically which application
I want to deal with this, and
I'm going to tell you upfront
this is the application that
can deal with this.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so the way
that we positioned this when
we first designed the Web
Intents spec was to say, well,
I could design multiple kind of
inputs into my application
for external developers
to call into.
But at the same time, if I've
got this way of taking the
data from the browser and
bringing it into the app, why
can't I just have my own
application's components
orchestrate and talk
to each other.
So you might have like an image
picker, and an image
editor, and like an image
saver all in one app.
But you can talk to them
yourself over intents, which
means that you don't have to
kind of reimplement your own
page to page.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it seems
like a really nice way of
decoupling that communication
that you're planning on doing
anyway, so that you can just--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, you can
basically just reuse all the
same existing architecture that
you have for external
parties internally inside
your own app.
PAUL LEWIS: I like it, sold.
PAUL KINLAN: Sold.
I was going to do a really
bad joke then.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
That's unusual for you.
PAUL KINLAN: Infomercials
and everything.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, great.
PAUL KINLAN: Like available in
14 days, just give my your
Visa, doesn't matter.
PAUL LEWIS: Don't go there.
PAUL KINLAN: So I think we
finished with the whole
presentation.
Obviously this is my blog,
which we don't
need to look at anymore.
Should we switch back
to the camera?
PAUL LEWIS: So we've got
some questions that
have been coming in.
Should we go through those?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, questions.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
So where to find out about
different kinds on Web
Intents, e.g. share.
So right now, webintents.org
would be the place to go.
So there's the specification
which says how the browser is
actually supposed to implement
Web Intents in themselves, but
the actual webintents.org right
now is acting as that
kind of point of reference
for a number of
specific intents, right?
So like there's share,
pick, edit, view--
PAUL KINLAN: Save.
PAUL LEWIS: --save.
Oo.
PAUL KINLAN: Subscribe.
PAUL LEWIS: Subscribe.
PAUL LEWIS: I always
forget subscribe.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, Julien
Genestoux really likes the
idea of subscribe, so we
implemented it for him.
But it's kind of cool, right?
So we have those, I think,
six core actions.
They're all documented
on webintents.org.
Yeah, we'll see how that
generally goes.
Just to let everyone know,
we're going to move
webintents.org to more of a
wiki-based architecture.
Just because it's open source
now, but it's on GitHub, it's
under some obscure directory
inside GitHub, which kind of
means that people aren't willing
to check it out and
manipulate the code, manipulate
the documentation.
So we're going to try a move
it to a wiki-based
architecture so that we can
iterate on the best practices
for each of the actions, and
also best guidance for how to
contribute.
PAUL LEWIS: It's a good point.
Because at this stage, it's
there in Chrome Apps, you can
use it, we want people to be
using it alongside their
existing integrations that
they're already doing, and
giving actual developer feedback
on how is this API to
use, what would be really
helpful, and all
these kinds of things.
And the same goes for the
documentation, and wikis, get
that feedback in.
And obviously, now is the time
to put it in, while the spec
is still being formed and the
documentation can be updated.
All right.
So webintents.org for that.
So being a provider requires
having an installed app.
How do you see Web Intents
working for browsers without
the concept of an installed
web app?
PAUL KINLAN: Hey, sweet.
So who's that from?
[? Mr. Mehamov? ?]
Ah, Mike.
Cool.
So the question is basically
saying, well--
PAUL LEWIS: Today it works
in the Chrome ecosystem.
PAUL KINLAN: Today it's all in
the Chrome ecosystem, all the
applications are delivered
by the Chrome Web Store.
Now the specification itself
on what we tried to do from
the start is basically
say, this idea of its
inter-application communication
shouldn't really
be tied down to kind
of one vendor.
It shouldn't be tied
down to one store.
So the idea behind intents was
that we were going to have a
tag inside HTML, which basically
says, well, any user
agent, whether it's a search
engine, or whether it's a
customer at the Chrome Web
Store, or just a someone
else's browser can crawl the
web and understand the
capabilities of different
websites.
So hypothetically google.com
crawls Imagemator.
Well, Imagemator is a bad
example because it doesn't
receive any data.
But Mememator receives images
via the edit intent.
Any search engine will go along,
understand that that
application supports the
ability to edit images.
And then when someone searches
for image editing software,
you can kind of go, well we know
what they're looking for,
let's give them the
app instead.
And then you'll click
on the link.
The browser, in that case,
should then register the fact
that that application can
support those actions
regardless of it being
installed or not.
So when the user then says,
well, I need to edit an image,
your web application will
appear in that list.
So there's a couple
ways of doing it.
And we're trying to do it via
the intent tag so that can
have a concise way of describing
the functionality
inside your application.
PAUL LEWIS: So the context
we're talking about Web
Intents today is Chrome Apps.
But it does have this sort of
broader use on the web.
Are there any shims or
anything like that?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, there's
webintents.org/webintents.
It's almost as if you kind of
set that one up for me to--
PAUL LEWIS: You know, I'm
the gift that keeps
on giving, my friend.
PAUL KINLAN: So we
have a shim.
I got a message today
though that the shim
doesn't work in Firefox.
I know about this.
I really need help, actually,
maintaining the shim.
It doesn't work in Firefox
because I enabled Content
Security Policy so people
couldn't inject code or
basically inject anything bad
into webintents.org domains if
they're shared across
sites essentially.
But it works in a really nice
way, it creates an iframe.
The parent page will talk to
webintents.org, which will
then proxy the data
across to other
applications in other tabs.
But, yeah, it needs some work,
it needs some love.
And if anyone wants to help make
webintents.org especially
the shim, better, and work
better on Firefox,
please let me know.
I'm also told it has some
issues with IE 9.
But I actually believe that was
because the user hadn't
actually registered any
external applications.
PAUL LEWIS: Juan asks, what's
the best way to start?
Are you asking the best way to
start with Chrome Apps or the
best way to start with
Web Intents?
PAUL KINLAN: Can we flick
back to our code?
Google Chrome.
So the best way to actually
start with Chrome Apps is
Chrome App samples on GitHub.
So if we can zoom in.
There is a way of zooming in.
Here we are.
There we are, github.com/Googl
eChrome/chrome-app-samples.
That will give you a list of
samples, which we're working
on to make a lot better, and
structured a lot nicer, make
it more friendly to
read through.
But that will give you at
least, I think, 20 or 30
different examples of
the APIs that are
available in Chrome Apps.
There's an explicit
Web Intents demo.
There's loads, there's loads.
There's even a Parrot AR.Drone
demo that we
made the other day.
So if you were available for
last week and you watched the
presentation that we had, we
basically showed you how to
build or interact with
an AR.Drone using
normal network sockets.
PAUL LEWIS: In this case, the
one you probably want is the
Hello World sample, which
will actually
go through the process.
Also, as we said before, if you
look at yeoman.io, you can
also install that.
That has a Chrome App generator
which you can then
use to actually create
effectively a Hello World
application.
It'll do all that
work for you.
And then you could actually look
at what it writes out and
just kind of dissect
that yourself.
So there are a couple
ways that you can
actually get that code.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And if you want to get started
on Web Intents, webintents.org
should get you started.
If you have any problems with
the documentation, it's a bug,
we need to fix that,
please let us know,
paulkinlan@google.com, or on
any of the GitHub issues.
We want to make that
documentation better, so you
can just get started
like that.
And is that the last question?
Should we do this one from
Anon at the end?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I guess.
Could you go into a
big of detail on
why extras were removed?
How much would you say the
intents concept diverges from
the Android original now?
And what are the key
distinctions
between the two presently?
And are there any other
chances of them
diverging even further?
PAUL KINLAN: So to deal with the
first one, a bit of detail
why extras were removed.
We found the API really
cumbersome.
So when you made an intent
object, then you would call
getExtra or setExtra.
And we were talking about
having, say, a dictionary of
extra pieces of metadata that
you would pass on instead.
So make it from like 10 API
calls to set 10 variables to
be one API call with
the dictionary.
But even that, people wanted
to pass extra data.
And this has all kind of come
back from developer feedback,
especially on the specification
group, is that
developers just wanted to
package that up into one
payload right at the start.
So when you declare your action
and type, you also
declare your data.
And we only use a string
today, which was
incorrect of me.
But it was for more of kind
of rapid prototyping.
It will turn into an object.
And the object will then
include, if you're saving a
file, would include
file name, size.
If you want to share and image,
it might include width
and height dimensions
at least.
The point being though is that
all of this should be
documented in best practices.
And this will come through the
wiki that we're hopefully
going to launch in the
near future at least.
So that's why we did extras.
The API, we didn't
like the API.
It didn't feel natural.
And we just wanted it to be one
object that you pass into
your WebKit Intent object.
Likewise, for the second
question, how much would you
say the intent--
It's diverged a little bit.
I mean, we have a similar
concept from Android Intents
at least where we have
the action, which
essentially is a string.
On Android it's reversed
domain notation, our is
obviously a normal domain.
PAUL LEWIS: Conceptually,
though, they're the same.
Your app says, look, I want to
do this thing, and another app
basically says, oh, I
could do that thing.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so
conceptually it's the same.
If you look at how you pass
extra data, Android does
differ from Chrome right now.
And we're not at the point where
we're going to have the
two systems interact
and operate just
yet, I don't think.
We want to make the best
experience for web developers.
And not all Java-based APIs fit
into the web ecosystem.
So we want to make the best API
for web developers to get
their applications
talking together.
And I'll just kind
of mention this.
A lot of people want to
talk to native apps.
They want to talk to the network
via Web Intents.
And they want to talk to like
Android apps or something from
the say the Chrome browser
or on Android itself.
The main goal of Web Intents
is to get web developers
making applications which
are more connected
than they are now.
So we're trying to solve that
problem to start off with.
And then we'll get to
the problems at some
point in the future.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, cool.
There's just one final question
that's just popped in.
Any plans to add quick links
to disable or remove
extensions, I guess apps
as well, directly
on the intent picker?
I found myself wanting to do so
after installing several at
a time to try, and it's a bit
unwieldy jumping to the
extension page, since you
forget which one.
Well first of all, this
is really good
actual real world feedback.
So thank you for that.
That's the first thing.
PAUL KINLAN: So we've got
defaulting in place.
How annoying.
So we've got defaulting.
So defaulting is basically
so you don't have to keep
selecting the same intent.
PAUL LEWIS: But at the moment,
am I right, if you select a
service, it's going to
automatically use that the
second time?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, the
second time around.
But the thing that happens, and
we'll show you in a second
when we do this.
We've only got like
a minute left.
We share a page.
So ideally we want to be able
to manage the list of
applications that appear
here from here.
It's a really great
piece of feedback.
I'll pass it to the
engineering team.
If I don't do it any time
soon, crbook.com is
the place to go.
Let me share to Gmail.
This is an extension
that we've written.
There's a little nib up here
called Use Another App.
So what happens with defaulting
is that defaulting
always calls the one that you
last used, which is always the
same one if don't use
a different app.
So Use Another App will
basically say, well, I'm going
to go back to the picker and
then let you reselect another
app And there's a bug in the
packaged app stuff where it
doesn't actually have that
little nib to say I want to
use a different application.
So if you actually use the
application that we had today,
it will keep going into it until
you uninstall it, which
is a known bug, and hopefully
it should be fixed.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
that was it.
I think we're done,
45 minutes.
Thank you for your questions.
We're going to be here
again next week.
The way that these work is we
are trying to get as much
feedback as possible about
what you want to hear.
Because we have a whole series
of talks that we want to talk
about, but if you want to know
how to build applications
which do networking, and I know
Paul did one last week,
but if you want to learn more
about networking, please let
us know because we will tailor
our presentations and kind of
this to suit your needs.
So if you want to know how to do
Hello World again, we could
do that one and then kind
of go into some
more advanced stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: Let us know
what you want.
Certainly now is the time to
give us that feedback.
We can tailor accordingly,
as Paul said.
But in the meantime, thank you
very much for joining us.
And we'll see you next time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, thank
you very much.
Bye.